bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat dans un instant vous allez pouvoir
suivre en direct la séance de questions
cribles elle est consacrée aujourd'hui à
la réforme de la justice
c'est michèle alliot marie garde des
sceaux ministre de la justice qui vient
répondre aux questions des sénateurs
une séance qui intervient alors que la
suppression envisagée des jurés
populaires fait polémique
aujourd'hui le débat a été lancé par le
député ump jean-paul garraud
il propose de créer en première instance
des tribunes des tribunaux criminels
départementaux composée uniquement de
magistrats et de juges selon le syndicat
de la magistrature
cela éloigne un peu plus le peuple de la
justice parmi elles les thèmes qui
devraient être abordés cet après midi
par les sénateurs il y aura aussi la
réforme de la carte judiciaire mais
aussi l'application de la loi
pénitentiaire c'est jean rené lecerf
rapporteur ump de ce texte au sénat
qu'ils interpellent la ministre à ce
sujet les autres thèmes seront aussi à
la garde à vue c'est un également un
thème cher aux sénateurs ils proposent
la présence d'un avocat dès les
premières heures de garde à vue
la ministre devra également s'expliquer
sur la calendrier de la réforme pénale
un calendrier qui suscite des
interrogations la réforme pénale en
effet été reportée plusieurs fois dans
un instant donc les questions cribles
dont je vous rappelle le principe le
sénateur dispose de deux minutes pour
poser sa question le ministre deux
minutes pour lui répondre
enfin un autre sénateur à la possibilité
éventuellement de répliquer pendant une
minute
donc tout de suite elle direction à
l'hémicycle je vous souhaite une très
bonne séance à tous
c'est
capable
ces anciens brise l'ordre du jour
appelle les questions cribles
thématiques sur la justice le point sur
la réforme
je vous rappelle l'auteur de la question
et nos ministres pour sa réponse
disposent chacun de deux minutes
une réplique d'une durée d'une minute
maximum peut être représenté soit par
l'auteur de la question soit par l'un
des membres de son groupe politique
chacun des orateurs ont à coeur de
respecter son temps de parole et vous
avez les afficheurs de chronomètre pour
vous aider la parole est ainsi
jean-pierre michel pour le groupe
socialiste
un merci monsieur le président de la mpt
la ministre d'état je souhaite vous
interroger sur l'application de la
réforme de la carte judiciaire et
notamment ses conséquences immobilière
en effet l'année dernière presque la
moitié des tribunaux qui visitent primé
l'ont été je passe pour l'édition des
dommages pour les justiciables notamment
éloigner les tribunaux d'instance mais
on voit aujourd'hui que les tribunaux
qui ont été accueillis ailleurs l'on
était dans le très mauvaises conditions
et que les services ont été éparpillés
c'est le cas dans mon département au 1er
janvier 2011 la chose va se corser si
j'ose dire puisque la totalité de la
réforme été réalisés et que des dizaines
de tribunaux de grande instance seront
supprimés et devant être accueillis par
un au tribunal de grande instance dans
le département concerné alors la
question que je me pose c'est dans
quelles conditions vont ils être avez
vous aujourd'hui des solutions pérennes
à proposer j'en doute quand on sait
comme l'a dit le rapport de la cour des
comptes qu entre la décision et
l'inauguration il faut entre 4 ou 5 ans
pour l'édifice public avez-vous donc des
solutions à titre provisoire et qu'elle
va être le coût de ces opérations
je ne vous demande pas de faire une
réponse orale complète aujourd'hui
mais cette recette simplement de me le
faire parvenir par écrit de la façon la
plus complète qui soit et enfin
je me demande si dans cette période
donné c'est faire d'économies
budgétaires le budget de votre ministère
mais la mainmise d'état pourra supporter
les coûts d'un tel programme immobilier
même si il était allé dans le temps et
s'il ne serait pas plus raisonnable de
surseoir à l'application complète cette
réforme qui a été très mal faite sans
aucune concertation
ça continue d'ailleurs dans les
départements en attendant que notre
économie accuse moins de déficit
qu'aujourd'hui je vous remercie
merci aux chefs des clans les temps
madame michèle alliot marie ministre
d'état garde des sceaux ministre de la
justice de liberté
madame la ministre monsieur le président
que monsieur le sénateur mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur michel
la réforme de la carte judiciaire avait
pour but de moderniser l'organisation de
notre justice dans son implantation
territoriale
ce travail a été largement fait et comme
je les dis il n'est pas de bonne
politique de remettre en cause une
réforme quand les décisions ont été
prises d'ailleurs ces décisions ont été
validés par le conseil d'état à partir
du moment où les décisions sont prises
il me revient effectivement de les
mettre en oeuvre dans les meilleures
conditions possibles
21 tribunaux de grande instance ont
fermé cette année dans la dernière phase
de la réforme de la carte judiciaire
donc on est déjà très avancé c'est la
raison pour laquelle il n'est possible
et je me souhaite ni arrêté ni reculer
les différentes étapes des regroupements
sont suivis par la chancellerie au plus
près des corps et des juridictions
concernées et vous le savez j'ai demandé
au secrétaire d'état d'aller directement
sur place pour s'entretenir avec les
intéressés et me faire regroupement par
regroupement l'état de la situation
aussi bien sur le plan immobilier que
sur le plan des personnels sur le plan
immobilier le regroupement des
juridictions représente une centaine
d'opérations très diverse d'ailleurs
pierre simple hier densification dans
certains cas ya la reconstruction que
dans d'autres sur le plan social nous
avons beaucoup avancé puisque des
solutions conformes aux souhaits des
personnels
sont mises en oeuvre pour les deux
centres en 63 fonctionnaires et les 123
président magistrats des tribunaux de
grande instance concernés on a également
un certain nombre d'aménagements
technologiques en la matière est ce que
je peux vous dire c'est que le coût
global de la réforme qui est estimez
vous le savez à 21 millions d'un peu
plus de 21 millions d'euros pour
l'accompagnement social à 20 millions
d'euros pour l'aide à la réinstallation
et à 386 millions d'euros sur cinq ans
pour l'immobilier seront bien respectés
et sont inscrits au fur et à mesure dans
le budget donc je vous donnerai si vous
le souhaitez le détaille point par point
comme vous le souhaitez mais il n'est
pas question d'interrompre cette mise en
main ce qui poserait d'ailleurs beaucoup
de problèmes puisque d'ores et déjà un
certain nombre de personnes ont eu leur
affectation nouvelle selon leurs désirs
il sera d'état pour la réplique la
parole et à jean-pierre michel jeu pas
une réplique par un baume ou la réplique
je veux remercier de la mobilité de sa
réponse lui dire que dans le département
que je représente ici les choses sont
claires la tribune des tribunaux de
grande instance a été supprimé 2
accueillis dans des conditions très
mauvaises à vesoul et allure les juges
rendent leur décision en justiciable
parce qu'il ne se déplace plus quant au
tribunal de grande instance de lure
il doit arriver avait au début de
l'année le secrétaire d'état à la
justice et bienvenue en août en haute
saône
les parlementaires n'ont pas été conviés
d'ailleurs à ces réunions ce qui est
pour le moins étonnant il s'est bien
gardé d'ailleurs d'interroger les
magistrats et les avocats n'étaient pas
de grande instance de lure qui vont être
supprimés car il savait l'écho qu'il
allait avoir
il s'est contenté avec les élus de la
ville de vesoul d'arpenter le
l'ancien hôpital qui étaient désertés au
profit d'un nouveau la ville de vesoul
désirant vendre cette emprise et ses
terrains cette opération était faite
serait évidemment la plus chère qui
pourrait se faire
mais comme votre collègue de secrétariat
et à la francophonie et maire de vesoul
peut-être se fera t-elle chers collègues
la parole et à madame nicole borvo
cohen-séat pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et des sénateurs du
parti de gauche
si monsieur le président à l'âme la
garde des sceaux
la loi du 5 mars 2007 a instauré la
collégialité de l'instruction suite à l'
affaire d'outreau cette réforme était à
notre sens peu ambitieuse mais la
collégialité étaient positives son
application était prévue pour cette
année 2010 c'était sans compter sur le
manque persistant en personnels de
justice et sur la volonté du président
de la république et du gouvernement de
supprimer les juges d'instruction et de
rendre le parquet m des procédures pour
l'heure la contestation soulevée par
votre projet de réforme vous amener à
surseoir à son examen puis d'alors des
dispositions de la loi de 2007
encore une fois dans tous les domaines
de la justice demeure à la question
criante et récurrente de ses moyens
l'application de la loi pénitentiaire
illustre parfaitement la suppression des
tribunaux d'instance éloigne le citoyen
de la justice c'est-à-dire met fin à la
proximité l'aide juridictionnelle
demeure dramatiquement inadaptée et
crédit de programme accès au droit et à
la justice ont même été réduits dans le
budget 2010 le budget de la justice en
france est un des plus faibles d'europe
il a augmenté de 3 5% en 2010 et mais
vous répéter non seulement c'est bien
peu mais magistrats et greffiers n'ont
rien vu une justice plus efficace et
plus rapide comme vous aimait à le
répéter oui sauf à refuser qu'elles
soient égales pour tous cela nécessite
d'accroître des crédits qui lui sont
alloués ma question est donc la suivante
la justice sous le couperet de la rgpp
de la diminution accrue des dépenses
publiques va-t-elle continuer à
s'appauvrir
ne pensez vous pas qu'il est urgent de
lui permettre de disposer de moyens
suffisants décent car dans le cas
contraire ce serait au béret sciemment
toute possibilité d'une réforme
permettant une justice accessible
compréhensible et juste pour nos
concitoyens
monsieur le ministre d'état madame le
sénateur depuis 2002 la justice qui
c'est vrai on en près d'un siècle a été
abandonné par les gouvernements
successifs et n'a pas bénéficié des
augmentations de crédits et de
personnels dont ont bénéficié d'autres
mystères
depuis 2002 donc a fait l'objet d'un
traitement positif très particulier et
depuis 2005
c'est l'un des très rares ministères qui
dans le cadre de la rgpp a vu son nombre
de magistrats et de fonctionnaires
augmenter ceux ci les chiffres vous
devez les connaître et ceux ci
continuera effectivement car nous avons
besoin de moderniser notre justice c'est
à dire de répondre à des évolutions
d'ailleurs notre société avec la
juridicisation croissante avec également
une tentation qui est celle de plaider
de plus en plus et donc nous avons toute
une série de dispositifs qui sont faits
pour moderniser la justice à la fois des
dispositifs tels que la réforme de la
carte judiciaire mais également des
dispositifs ayant trait à la réforme de
la procédure pénale à la réforme de
l'aide judiciaire à la réforme de la
procédure civile à la réforme des
procédures elle-même avec notamment le
développement de la mer de la médiation
et de la conciliation avec tout ceci et
vêtements c'est une justice apte à
répondre à la fois aux demandes des
justiciables à répondre à l'évolution de
notre société et surtout à remplir son
rôle de ciment de la société et d'unité
de la société parce que le contentieux
c'est aussi un affrontement et c'est
bien la raison pour laquelle j'entends
développer la médiation et la
conciliation qui sont des façons de ne
pas aller jusqu'au contentieux et de
préserver donc l'unité sociale et le
tissu social de notre société
contrairement à ce qui a été fait par un
certain nombre de gouvernements
dans le passé y compris ceux auxquels
votre groupe participer il y à un effort
très déterminé en faveur d'une
modernisation de notre justice est
d'ailleurs aussi notre système
pénitentiaire
merci ministre d'état madame nicole
borvo cohen seat
oui je n'ignore pas que la justice ait
délaissé depuis fort longtemps
je constate que depuis effectivement dix
ans notre pays est passé en matière de
dépenses de justice du 27e rojo 29e
neuvième des pays européens donc bien
entendu augmentation des crédits mais
judiciarisation de la société ce que je
ne partage pas forcément mais le constat
est là c'est que les moyens de la
justice se sont totalement insuffisants
et d'ailleurs je voudrais quand même
cité la réforme envisagée puisque nous
en avons eu l'écho par la presse comme
possible des courbes acides des courbes
assises nous fait frémir
outre le fond dont on aura sans doute
peut-être l'occasion de discuter sur des
jugement de premier instance différents
sous une forme différente en deuxième
instance sur la queue dans des procès
criminels
je constate que l'on dit que le
fonctionnement des cours d'assises et
roland et qu'on veut une justice plus
rapide d'accords dans ces conditions
dans les conditions actuelles
on manque de jugement manque de
greffiers on manque de tribunaux donc
dire que le remède
à la lenteur des cours d'assises c'est
de supprimer les jurys populaires c'est
quand même fort de café passez moi
l'expression
donc on va se demander si la justice
fonctions régaliennes s'il en est ne va
pas se trouver obligés de faire du
partenariat public privé non seulement
pour construire des bâtiments mais
peut-être pour payer aussi les
magistrats si mes chers collègues
la parole est à monsieur jean rené
lecerf pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire chaque collègue
madame le ministre d'état je
souhaiterais faire le point sur la mise
en oeuvre de la loi pénitentiaire et
donc sur la publication des textes
nécessaires à son application si
l'assignation à résidence avec
surveillance électronique qui permettra
de limiter le recours à la détention
provisoire a fait l'objet d'un décret du
4 avril du 10 avril dernier qu'en est-il
de l'obligation d'activité obligation
d'activité l'une des mesures phares de
cette loi qui suppose que des
initiatives soient prises au front d
opportunité renouvelée de travail ou de
formation professionnelle en milieu
carcéral
je rappelle que cette obligation
d'activité qui prévoit une consultation
des personnes détenues sa compagne en
contrepartie d'une aide en nature ou en
numéraire aux personnes indigentes dans
le cadre du développement du travail
carcéral
les représentants du gouvernement
s'était d'ailleurs engagé lors des
débats parlementaires à mettre en
chantier une réforme du code des marchés
permettant d'attribuer un droit de
préférence à équivalence d'offres aux
entreprises donnant du travail aux
personnes détenues ou aux services
pénitentiaires de l'emploi où en sommes
nous de même beaucoup d'espoirs reposent
sur l'élaboration de règlements
intérieurs cadre commun à chaque
catégorie d'établissements
pénitentiaires maison d'arrêt centre de
détention maison centrale qui
permettrait enfin une solution globale à
des problèmes quotidiens
particulièrement sensibles comme le coût
des cantines ou de la location des
téléviseurs ou comme l'incitation à
l'usagé de formule classique de
politesse madame monsieur et au
vouvoiement
enfin le contrôleur général des lieux de
privation de liberté a exprimé devant la
commission des lois de notre assemblée
sont sous son souci
voir respecter la confidentialité des
courriers qu'ils échangent avec les
personnes détenues qu'en est il
aujourd'hui avec la loi pénitentiaire
nous sommes nombreux à être convaincus
d'avoir voté un texte fondateur
il convient qu avec l'aide du
gouvernement et de l'administration
pénitentiaire il puisse s'appliquer dans
son intégralité le plus rapidement
possible je sais que vous y veiller à
madame le ministre d'état et je vous en
remercie ont chacun par l'état - michèle
alliot-marie ministre d'état garde des
sceaux ministre de la justice et des
libertés
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur lesage effectivement ma
première responsabilité c'est de mettre
en oeuvre la loi pénitentiaire tel que
vous l'avez voter et en particulier sur
le problème de l'activité vous savez
j'ai moi même souhaité que soient
inscrits les cinq heures par jour et par
détenu d'activité parce que c'est un
élément très important de lutte contre
la récidive
à travers les possibilités de
réinsertion et c'est également une façon
de faire sans doute baisser la violence
qui existe dans nos établissements
il est vrai que ça se passe dans un
contexte difficile puisque c'est un
contexte de crise c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai réactivé un certain nombre
de contacts destinés à fournir de
l'activité c'est ainsi que j'ai eus
n'augurerait d'ici quelques semaines le
troisième centre d'appels dans la prison
des femmes de versailles
d'autre part j'ai également relancer le
partenariat avec le medef et j'ai signé
il doit y avoir à peu près 15 jours ou
trois semaines
une convention avec la fondation m6 pour
le développement des activités
culturelles en prison et pour des sommes
non négligeables
la caisse des dépôts et consignations
après trois expériences réussies
d'implantation de cyber base qui ont
pour but de donner aux jeunes le goût de
l'école via l'hostis 2
multimédia va financer de nouveaux
projets dans chacune des régions
pénitentiaire sur la formation
professionnelle cinq régions françaises
s'engagent dans l'expérimentation
permise par l'article 9 de la loi pour
une modification pour la formation
professionnelle des détenus sur le droit
de préférence enfin je vous confirme que
j'ai obtenu l'accord du ministère de
l'économie pour une modification en ce
sens du code des marchés publics
en ce qui concerne l'élaboration des
règlements intérieurs le décret
d'application est prêt il va être
bientôt publié et il prévoit
effectivement tout ce qui concerne la
vie en détention
enfin sur la confidentialité des
correspondances adressées au contrôleur
général des lieux privatifs de liberté
j'ai décidé d'étendre communications
téléphoniques
cette confidentialité et j'ai rappelé
très fermement les consignes aux
directeurs des établissements tim hui
sur des tannins pour la réplique
c'est un oui mesdames bis des tâches
mais d'abord vous remercier pour les
informations très utiles que vous nous
apportez
j'aurais pu vous interroger sur la mise
en place d'autres structures qu'il
s'agisse de l'observatoire national de
la délinquance
qu'il s'agisse de la réserve civile
pénitentiaire qu'il s'agisse des
nouvelles commissions de discipline mais
mon propos ne visaient pas à
l'exhaustivité mon propos visait
simplement à rappeler que cette loi
pénitentiaire pour l'ensemble des
parlementaires est un texte fondateur et
qu' il impose un changement de culture
par rapport à ce qui se passait jusqu'à
présent de façon à ce que plus jamais la
prison ne soit ce qu'elle était encore
en 2000
une humiliation pour la république notre
préoccupation fondamentale elle est là
et si je puis ajouter un dernier souhait
c'est le souhait que l'administration
pénitentiaire s'ouvre davantage vers la
transparence et que notamment elles
répondent plus facilement favorablement
aux demandes de visites qui sont faites
par ceux dont c'est la profession est
d'informer les citoyens car je crois que
pour que les français se réapproprie les
prisons de la république il faut qu'il
sache très précisément ce qui s'y passe
je vous remercie
merci mon cher collègue la parole est un
sujet michel millet pour le groupe
du rassemblement démocratique et social
européen c'est le président madame le
ministre
à mon tour je souhaite parler de la loi
pénitentiaire que vous avez d'ailleurs
âprement défendu et qui devait en fait
permettre l'application dans
l'établissement dépressif les plus
élémentaires de la dignité la personne
humaine cela vient d'être appelé
d'ailleurs et donc mettre fin à la
situation intolérable dans laquelle se
trouvent nos prisons connaissez les
problèmes surpopulation carcérale
insalubrité sur-représentation
pathologie mentale les maux qui frappent
notre système carcéral en disent long
sur l'état général de notre justice qui
finalement au vu de tout cela est l'une
des pires d'europe
pourtant de prime abord l'isatis
gouvernement avait été favorablement
accueillie il était temps que les
pouvoirs publics se saisissent de cette
grave question et nombre d'entre nous se
sont hélas rapidement rendu compte que
l'application de cette loi ne changeait
pas la situation des personnes détenues
et pas davantage celle des personnels
pénitentiaires en tout cas pas dans les
proportions que nous aurions tous
souhaité à l'occasion des débats les
radicaux de gauche avaient formulé des
réserves prononciation principe de
l'encellulement individuel prise en
charge psychiatrique du droit la
formation du régime disciplinaire ou de
celui des fouilles
or la politique sécuritaire du
gouvernement n'a fait qu'alimenter les
flux d'entrée à l'établissement
pénitentiaire sans que ne soient même
mener une réelle réflexion sur les
politiques de réinsertion est loin de
réseaux de cette situation
cette politique a été sévèrement
critiquée par le comité contre la
torture des nations unies dans les
observations présentées le 14 mai
dernier
le contrôleur général des lieux de
privation de liberté dans son dernier
rapport
ça a été aussi rappelé noter que les
personnes sortent rarement de prix entre
man que brisées ou révoltées et sigma
tease et le passage au passage le fait
que la sécurité est devenue un prétexte
à l'extension des limitations des droits
et libertés alors madame le garde des
sceaux cas et vous aujourd'hui répondre
à ces critiques qui émanent d'autorité à
la légitimité incontestable
quand allez vous déplacer dépassés les
déclarations de bonnes intentions pour
mettre en fait notre droit pénitentiaire
en conformité avec les valeurs de la
république que je crois nous partageons
merci on cherche que d'examens et
michèle alliot marie ministre d'état
garde des sceaux ministre de la justice
liberté monsieur by day vous êtes un
parlementaire trop expérimenté pour ne
pas voir une petite pointe de mauvaise
foi dans ce que vous dites
la loi pénitentiaire a été votée il ya
combien il ya sept mois et vous demander
elles produisent immédiatement ses
effets s'agissant des mesures simples de
construction alors oui monsieur baye
laye depuis 2002 les programmes de
construction pénitentiaires n'ont jamais
été aussi importants et ils se
produisent et il y a régulièrement
plusieurs ouvertures de nouvelles
prisons chaque année ce qui nous permet
de désengorger et de ce point de vue le
programme est bien tenu et vous le savez
le président de la république a même
décidé de mettre de créer 5000 places
supplémentaires au delà des programmes
et notamment du 13200 déjà engagée pour
pouvoir faire baisser encore cela et
j'ai pris effectivement un engagement et
vous savez que j'ai dit qu'il fallait
être réaliste aussi parce que c'était
pas du jour au lendemain que l'on paré
pouvait arriver à voir le nombre de
places permettant un encellulement
individuel surtout si on doit tenir
compte aussi du fait que vous avez une
surpopulation dans certaines régions et
non surpopulation dans d'autres donc je
crois qu'il faut être aussi réaliste en
la matière jamais il n'y a eu autant de
faits et il est faux de dire d'ailleurs
qu'il y aurait une populaire une
politique sécuritaire qui augmenterait
les flux d'entrée puisque nous allons au
contraire une baisse du nombre des
personnes en détention et une baisse
sensible au cours de ces dernières
années
ce qui fait d'ailleurs qu'en 2015 on
devrait avoir globalement encore une
fois globalement parce que je dis les
choses réellement au moins autant de
place que deux personnes incarcérées le
un encellulement individuel théorique
sera effectivement possible en la
matière alors par ailleurs il y à
d'autres mesures qui sont prises et dont
je viens de parler en répondant à
monsieur le surf et
et les mesures d'application sont
effectivement en cours puisque trois
décrets d'application vont être publiées
dans les prochaines semaines les deux
premiers sont exclusivement
pénitentiaire et ils sont liés l'un
porte sur les droits et obligations des
détenus ainsi que sur des dispositions
relevant du personnel par exemple code
de déontologie l' usage des armes etc
il est au conseil d'état le troisième
décret porte sur l'aménagement des
peines justement c'est un décret simple
et la rédaction doit en être achevés
dans les jours qui viennent
on a eu des concertations très large
sicile explique le temps qui a été
nécessaire
je pense qu'en la matière nous répondons
effectivement à tout ça j'ai dit les
autres points sur lesquels nous
travaillons et je viens de vous re et je
voudrais vous rappeler que nous venons
d'inaugurer la première unité
hospitalière spécialement aménagée pour
les détenus présentant des troubles
psychiatriques lourds et que la deuxième
le sera en juin 2011
monsieur miles est je voudrais bien
savoir quel autre gouvernement depuis
des décennies a fait autant pour la
situation pénitentiaire
merci au lycée d'état ne parle et et
jean michel baylet
madame alliot marie vous êtes une
politique suffisamment expérimenté pour
savoir que korn consécutivement un
parlementaire de la majorité et aux
parlementaires de l'opposition vous
interroge ce même sujet c'est qu'il est
un problème réel et profond
il ne sert à rien de vouloir cacher
derrière notre petit doigt
j'ai reconnu ce qui avait été fait que
cette loi allait dans le bon sens mais
j'ai l'impression d'avoir déclenché
votre courroux ce qui prouverait que je
ne peux taper juste parce que il est
vrai que quand même
nous ne pouvons nous satisfaire de la
situation pénitentiaire d'aujourd'hui
elle est une des plus mauvaises des
nations d'europe en tout cas de leurs
hôtes de l'europe attaché aux valeurs
des droits de l'homme et de la
république et la démocratie et il y a
nécessité d'intervenir
vous avez lancé des projets
il est légitime que nous soyons un
patient quant au mans la situation de
nos prisons et le temps que nous
mettrons pour mettre en place des peines
de substitution si mon cher que les
paroles et un françois zocchetto pour le
groupe union centriste
merci monsieur le président madame le
ministre d'état à la faveur du projet de
loi relatif à la réforme des chambres de
commerce
il est envisagé que la profession
d'expert comptable se dote d'un fonds de
règlement pour recevoir des fonds et
pour donner quittance pour le compte des
clients alors sur la forme nous sommes
un peu surpris par cette innovation
majeure qui est introduite par le biais
d'un amendement subrepticement avancé en
cours de débat à l'assemblée nationale
deuxièmement cette réforme intéresse en
premier lieu les professionnels du droit
il ne semble pas que le ministère de la
justice ait été associée à sa
préparation est en tout cas au sein du
parlement les professions concerner les
commissions concernées que son
commission des lois de l'assemblée
nationale et du sénat n'ont pas débattu
par ailleurs cette innovation semble
entériner un pseudo accord entre
quelques représentant la profession
d'avocat et certains membres de l'ordre
des experts comptables sur le principe
mais maintenant chacun conviendra que le
maniement des fonds pour compte d'autrui
doit être strictement encadré
actuellement deux professions opère
majoritairement pour le compte d'autrui
ce sont bien sûr les notaires depuis
très longtemps est également depuis très
longtemps les avocats par le biais des
carpates qui ont fait l'objet de pas mal
d'encadrement et de modifications ces
derniers temps alors moi je pense qu'il
faut au moins trois conditions pour
pouvoir monter ce type de fonds
autrement que de façon hasardeuse
premièrement il faut le respect d'une
déontologie et d'une discipline stricte
à cet égard je m'interroge sur la
possibilité pour les commissaires aux
comptes de manier des condés des fonds
pour le compte d'autrui
deuxièmement le maniement de fond
résulte de l'exercice de missions
spécifiques de rédaction d'actes ou de
résolution des conflits tel que le font
les notaires ou les avocats enfin il
doit s'agir d'une mission de service
public et non d'une convenance pour
faire des affaires tout simplement alors
madame le ministre d'état je voudrais
savoir quelle est votre opinion sur
cette question merci merci chers
collègues la parole est à mme michèle
alliot marie ministre d'état garde des
sceaux ministre de la justice de liberté
merci monsieur le président monsieur
qu'est tour que même si ça n'est pas le
garde des sceaux qui a défendu le projet
de loi relatif à la réforme des réseaux
consulaires au commerce à l'artisanat et
aux services
je sais effectivement que ce texte que
vous verrez d'ailleurs demain je crois
qu'il vient demain et après demain
devant le sénat comporte sur la base
d'un amendement un assouplissement de
l'interdiction faite aux
experts-comptables d'accepter un mandat
ou de recevoir ou de conserver ou de
délivrer des fonds ou des valeurs donc
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
qu'on leur permet effectivement le
maniement de fond lorsque cette
opération s'effectue bien entendu à
titre accessoire et que cela ne peut se
faire que via un fonds de spécifique un
fonds de règlement
créé à cet effet par le conseil
supérieur de l'ordre des experts
comptables
cette dérogation est donc très limité et
d'autre part elle ne permettra pas que
les sommes en jeu de transit par les
comptes des professionnels et ça je
pense que c'était effectivement un point
très important
alors vous l'avez dit il faut que de
façon ceci soit très encadrée
effectivement le fonctionnement et les
modalités du fonds seront fixées par un
décret en conseil d'état
quel est le but de cette modification
telle que je la comprends c'est qu'elle
va permettre de placer les experts
comptables français dans la même
situation que leurs homologues européens
puisque l'interdiction n'existe pas dans
la plupart des pays européens
or vous le savez il ya des problèmes
effectivement de concurrence qui se
posent au niveau européen et pour toutes
les professions du droit et j'étais il y
à une heure devant le barreau de paris
ma préoccupation c'est aussi de les
mettre en situation de pouvoir faire
face à une concurrence souvent
extrêmement vive est extrêmement
dynamique de lapin
deux cabinets ou de profession mais
étrangères et en particulier anglo saxon
donc je crois que c'est ça l'idée de
cette réforme sur laquelle vous aurez à
vous prononcer demain et a promis tous
merci madame le ministre d'état la
question est importante non seulement
pour les professionnels concernés mais
surtout pour tous les usagers du droit
que sont les français
nous sommes un certain nombre ici à
penser que les dispositions envisagées
ne donne aucune garantie en terme de
sécurité des opérations juridiques tant
pour les particuliers que pour les
entreprises
et personnellement mais je sais que je
ne suis pas le seul mois je souhaiterais
que ces dispositions soient dans
l'immédiat retiré du projet de loi sur
la réforme des des chambres consulaires
et qu'ils puissent faire l'objet d'une
concertation préalable et d'un examen
approfondi et spécifiques parlement par
le parlement notamment à la lumière
aussi des explications complémentaires
que voudrait bien nous donner les
services de la chancellerie merci merci
mon cher collègue la parole et à
jean-pierre sueur pour le groupe
socialiste
ainsi monsieur le président annonce
contre-annonces renvoi report recul
madame le garde des sceaux
11 on s'y perd hier on nous annonce la
suppression du juge d'instruction
aujourd'hui la suppression du jury
populaire dans certaines circonstances
ne pensez vous pas que la multiplication
des effet d'annonce e nuit à la clarté
de la politique et pour venir à quelques
sujets concrets
vous n'ignorez pas qu'il ya eu le
rapport guinchard qui a donné lieu à un
projet de loi adopté par le conseil des
ministres le 3 mars
est ce que cela va donner lieu à une
suite pour alléger les procédures et les
contentieux e laquelle voilà une
question précise
l'adaptation de notre droit à la cour
pénale internationale
vous n'ignorez pas madame le ministre
d'état que le sénat a délibéré là dessus
le 10 juin 2008 et que cela est toujours
en rade donc un oeil aura-t-il un jour à
une inscription de cela à l'ordre du
jour de l'assemblée nationale de telle
manière que ce texte puisse voir le jour
et puis enfin là le projet de loi sur la
procédure pénale
vous n'ignorez pas les critiques
auxquelles ce projet de loi a donné lieu
notamment de la part de la cour de
cassation madame la ministre vous
n'ignorez rien de tout cela
plutôt que de procéder tous les mois à
des annonces différentes au terme
desquelles il ressort que cela est
différée
ne pensez vous pas qu'il serait bien de
sa tâche et à quelques règles concrètes
premièrement revoir la garde à vue la
présence des avocats
deuxièmement assurer l'indépendance des
parquets et troisièmement assurer cette
collégialité des juges d'instruction qui
est l'état actuel du droit que le
gouvernement a pour tâche vous le savez
de mettre en oeuvre je vous remercie mon
cher collègue madame la ministre d'état
monsieur cohérence réforme d'ensemble
détermination et avancer quoi qu'il en
soit je crois que c'est bien la ligne du
gouvernement et nous avançons et d'une
façon cohérente dans le cadre de la
procédure pénale
il est nécessaire de supprimer le juge
d'instruction parce que il est contraire
au principe européen puisqu'il ne
garantit pas les principes européens de
l'équité du jugement tels qu'ils sont
définis ses parents l'enquète et celui
qui juge de l'enquète
donc si le parquet justement répond plus
que le juge d'instruction
chacun dit que la réforme est nécessaire
là elle est obligatoire et c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous la ferons nous
le ferons selon la méthode que j'ai
préconisé sur la base d'une discussion
claire et cette discussion elle a eu
lieu quarante cinq syndicats et
associations ont participé à la
discussion et y compris les syndicates
qui avait dit qu'il se retirait de la
concertation ont apporté leur
contribution en faisant des propositions
d'amendements et de modification au
terme des dix semaines de discussions
nous avons 500 propositions de
modifications émanant de tout le monde
et nous sommes en train avec le groupe
qui m'entoure de reprendre tout dans ces
propositions toutes celles qui sont
utiles d'où qu'elle vienne pour les
intégrer à ce texte
ceci sera fini à la fin de la semaine
prochaine et le texte pourra ensuite
après les derniers arbitrages
nécessaires est renvoyé au conseil
d'état
dans le même temps l'étude d'impact a
été faite réajusté en fonction des
modifications et donc nous avons une
idée très précise de ce que cela peut
entraîner
en ce qui concerne je suis heureux que
vous m'en parliez la suppression du jury
populaire
j'ai effectivement lu des choses qui
n'ont ni queue ni tête dans un certain
nombre de journaux si on ne se référer
pas à des rumeurs mais si on nous
demandait ce qu'il en est j'aurais pu
dire effectivement qu'il n'est pas
question de supprimer les cours
d'assises ni les jurys populaires mais
simplement nous avons un vrai problème
et je vous le dis à vous tous qui
représentait la légitimité populaire
c'est que aujourd'hui vous avez des
milliers de crimes qui sont chaque année
déclassifiés considérés comme des délits
est jugée comme des délits ne répondons
pas à ce que vous avez décidé pour punir
de tels actes et là nous avons un vrai
problème d'autant que la lourdeur des
cas et des cours d'assises dans les
villes font que dans les villes on
correctionnalisé les crimes tandis que
ça ne se fait pas dans les régions de
province
alors là nous avons un vrai problème et
c'est la raison pour laquelle
il faut trouver une solution et dans les
solutions nous avons examiné tout ce qui
a été proposé dont effectivement dans le
passé certains avaient proposé la
création d'un tribunal criminel
aujourd'hui aucune décision n'est fait
nous cela fait partie des hypothèses sur
lesquelles nous sommes en train de
travailler
tout ceci vous montre une chose et j'en
termine par la pardonnez moi monsieur le
président c'est que la réforme de la
procédure pénale
elle est globale elle est cohérente elle
comporte aussi bien les problèmes de la
garde à vue que ceux du des cours
d'assises que ceux du juge d'instruction
et l semaine et elle avance
et effectivement le gouvernement tient à
la ligne tient le cap pour la réplique à
madame alima boumédiene thiery mini
madame la ministre vous justifiez votre
recul par la cohérence la réforme
d'ensemble la détermination c'est ce que
vous avez dit à chaque fois vous dites
nous avons le temps nous allons la
préparer bientôt vous allez la voir à
chaque fois vous nier le fait que en
fait quelque part cette réforme soit
presque enterré puisque même dans les
discussions plusieurs partenaires se
sont retirés nous avons ici à chaque
fois essayé de revenir sur la question
essentielle de la garde à vue par
exemple c'est une question essentielle
parce que nous le savons des milliers de
personnes aujourd'hui se retrouve en
garde à vue et sont victimes de
violations des droits humains
alors nous avons ici au parlement
à plusieurs reprises trois reprises
déposé des propositions de loi sur cette
garde à vue
à chaque fois vous nous avez opposer
systématiquement cette réforme globale
de la procédure pénale qui devait venir
or cette réforme de la procédure pénale
est bien pour nous elle est devenue
pratiquement une arlésienne
cette réforme nous l'attendons encore et
toujours
donc il est
important de vous rappeler que dans
plusieurs rapports y compris ceux d'
amnistie internationale de la ligue des
droits de l'homme et jean je pourrais en
citer beaucoup la garde à vue est
pointée du doigt à chaque fois on en
reparle comme une véritable honte pour
notre république
alors je vous en prie madame la ministre
en tant que parlementaire je voulais
vous dire simplement que nous n'allons
pas rester les bras ballants devant
l'inertie du gouvernement
nous avons décidé et d'ailleurs monsieur
le président de la commission l'a dit à
plusieurs reprises nous avons décidé de
revenir à la charge sur cette garde à
vue parce que c'est un élément une
question essentielle aujourd'hui nous ne
pouvons plus et tout le monde judiciaire
est d'accord avec nous nous ne pouvons
plus attendre sur cette question merci
mes chers collègues ta parole est à jean
jacques hyest pour le groupe union pour
un mouvement populaire
merci monsieur le président madame le
garde des sceaux madame le miz d'état
mes chers collègues est le 3 février
dernier après une altercation la veille
à sortie de son collège
une adolescente est interpellé par la
police à son domicile
selon cette dernière a été arrêtée en
temps d'une nuit menotté pendant son
transfert au commissariat
et cela pour un banal différend entre
collégiens
je ne saurais madame le miz et à juger
de l'entière certitude des faits ici
relaté
mais il n'en reste pas moins que les
incidents matière de garde à vue sont
bien réels et de plus en plus nombreux
ceci pour presque quotidiennement par
les médias concours malheureusement la
banalisation de la garde à vue les
chiffres vous les avez donné vous même
madame le garde des sceaux 1994 308
personnes en garde-à-vue 2009 800 me
regarde ces chiffres le premier ministre
a déclaré le 21 novembre 2009
la garde à vue est un acte grave qui ne
doit pas être envisagé comme un élément
de routine par les enquêteurs
nous avons constitué un groupe de
travail d'ailleurs avec jean pierre
michel et jean reno cf
sur ces sujets pour bien montrer que
c'est une préoccupation de tous le sénat
plusieurs propositions de loi ont été
déposées et nous avons dit il faut
l'examiner
les examiner dans une réforme d'ensemble
c'est pourquoi nous les avons renvoyés
en commission mais néanmoins on ne peut
pas attendre indéfiniment
madame le ministre d'état vous avez
indiquée et je comprends que la réforme
sur l'ensemble de la procédure pénale
faisait un ensemble mais néanmoins la
garde à vue quand même est un problème
spécifique quelle que soit l'évolution
du texte sur la réforme de la procédure
pénale
je pense que d'ailleurs ça diminue et il
suffit de dire qu'on va la réforme et
pour ça diminue c'est comme la détention
provisoire pouvez-vous nous garantir
madame ne misent dé tâter dispositions
relatives à la garde à vue pourront
faire l'objet prioritairement après tout
si vous déposez l'ensemble du projet de
loi
au moins cet aspect des choses pour être
examinés dans des délais rapides je
crois qu'il en va quand même de la
dignité des personnes
et de skier constitue quand même la
défense des libertés publiques
merci mon cher collègue madame la
ministre du top merci monsieur le
président monsieur le président y est
oui vous avez raison de rappeler que la
garde à vue est aujourd'hui trop
importante et que son régime doit être
modernisée et c'est bien ce sur quoi
nous travaillons
alors j'ai bien entendu madame
boumediene materi trouvez que c'est
roland je me réjouis que cette
impatience est dans le même temps
d'ailleurs il ya très peu de temps elle
se trouvait que je ne prenais pas
suffisamment de temps pour la
concertation et qu'il faudrait six mois
au moins de concertation c'est un peu
curieux comme comme phénomène mais moi
en tout état de cause je n'écoute rien
en la matière vous savez quand j'ai
décidé d'un calendrier
j'avance j'avance et je vous ferai
remarquer qu effectivement j'ai par
rapport à ce que j'ai annoncé au mois
d'octobre de l'année dernière 15 jours
de retard vous y 15 jours de retard sur
une année et sur une réforme qui
bouleverse complètement qui refonde la
procédure pénale c'est sans doute peu
comme je l' ai dit tout à l'heure nous
finissons de finaliser le texte
le texte effectivement dès qu'il
reviendra au conseil d'état sera déposée
globalement sur le bureau de l'assemblée
et monsieur le président je vous ai près
opposé comme au président de la
commission
les lois de l'assemblée que nous
découvrions alors ce texte puisque le
texte global représentera environ 13
cents articles
et même si une bonne partie sont à droit
constant avec simplement une réécriture
il est évident que ça ne peut pas passer
en une seule fois et qu'il faudra que
nous le regardons dans ce découpage
effectivement la garde à vue va
intervenir au moment de l' enquête
elle en fait partie alors bien entendu
nous pourrons examiner la garde à vue
mais ce qu'il faut bien voir c'est que
ces dispositifs sur la garde à vue que
nous avons mis améliore sensiblement la
situation mais ne peuvent pas être
complètement détachée d'un certain
contexte parce que justement nous
apportons des garanties supplémentaires
qui sont liées à ce contexte
dans la nouvelle réforme il ya par
exemple plus de contradictoire
nous donnons aussi à l'avocat notamment
dans la garde à vue
beaucoup plus de possibilités
d'intervenir ce qui est logique avec moi
le contradictoire mais est-ce que ça un
sens d'introduire le contradictoire dans
la garde à vue si ensuite il n'existe
plus pendant toute la procédure jusqu'au
moment où on va devant le tribunal
c'est une véritable difficulté alors
bien entendu il ya des mesures qui se
séparent telles que celles qui
permettent d'entendre des personnes sans
qu'elle soit en garde à vue sur des cas
relativement simple et claire il
yad'autres mesure où il faut un
découpage que nous ferons ensemble parce
qu'effectivement il doit représenter un
bloc de 200 ou 300 articles mais que ça
n'est pas toujours facile pour garder la
cohérence et surtout l'efficacité du
texte nous le ferons ensemble dès cet
été et ça nous permettra sans doute
d'avoir dans le courant des mois
suivants la possibilité d'examiner un
texte
merci mon ami c'est rita jean jacques
hyest
merci la game et les états effectivement
je pense que il faut commencer par un
morceau asn réforme d'ensemble nous
n'aurons pas fini
au bout de trois mois parce que c'est
quand même une réforme considérable
néanmoins madame le garde des sceaux je
pense qui peut être appelé et quand même
c'est sous l'autorité des parquets les
parquets peuvent avoir une action
vis-à-vis des forces de police pour le
rappeler que la garde à vue n'est pas
quelque chose de banal
et pourquoi le ciné parc a été actif
dans ce domaine je vous assure bien que
le nombre de gardes à vue diminuerait je
pense quand même que là aussi il ya un
rôle de des procureurs et je considère
que de ce point de vue il ya encore des
progrès à faire en attendant la grande
réforme que nous espérons tous
si mon cher que les méchins collègues
devaient suspendre la séance elles sont
reprises à 18 heures pour la suite de
l'examen du projet de bornes actif la
démence et la fin de cette séance de
questions cribles consacrée à la réforme
de la justice si vous souhaitez la
revoir notre site internet
publicsenat.fr
à suivre le journal de 18h présenté ce
soir par michel grossiord merci de votre
fidélité et à très bientôt sur public
sénat